québec se prépare à venir en aide à la
minière stornoway le gouvernement a
adopté un décret qui permet à
investissement québec d'acquérir une
partie des actifs de la mine renard et
de verser des sommes supplémentaires
pour permettre la poursuite des
activités
cette mine de diamants devait être le
grand projet de relance du plan nord
dans lequel le gouvernement et la caisse
de dépôt ont investi près d'un demi
milliard de dollars mais la chute du
prix du diamant et une dette trop élevée
ont poussé l'entreprise au bord du
gouffre la mine compte 550 employés avec
nos pierres fait tiquer jeune ministre
de l'économie de l'innovation avec qui
on va parler de quelques sujets mon
recommencer sur store doré bonsoir se
fatiguer bonne en studio stornoway donc
on va faire quoi fsma québec va prendre
le contrôle de story n'était pas l'image
que pour annoncer formellement le plein
parce que le décret ministériel qui
public mettant comme vous avez dit
mandaté vestissement québec credo
négocié avec les parties prenantes ce
que je faisais ce soir c'est que nous
avons décidé collectivement de sauver la
mine et de la garder en opération et on
devrait avoir une annonce cet effet la
semaine prochaine pourquoi elle a souri
et il va depuis hier plusieurs options
la première option c'est de l'affirmer
complètement milliard étaient investis
tous des preneurs tous les créanciers de
ce tournoi était contre cette idée
l'offre c'est quand même un potentiel de
cette nuit là se retourne dans le passé
avait des problèmes au niveau humain est
opérationnel les problèmes ont été
réglés en grande partie dont fait face à
deux problèmes le problème d'avoir des
pierrick sont abyssales en termes de
structure et deuxièmement très bas et
deuxièmement on a soudain capital qui
était pas approprié pour le risque je
m'explique trop de deux montent à payer
un intérêt des redevances des royautés
alors tous les créanciers
on parle présentement tous les
créanciers via le sma québec pour y
avait une solution et on pense qu'on est
capable de l'annoncer à son prochain et
on nous demandait ouvertement exactement
bâtiment québec et donc ça ressemble à
une restructuration placer l'entreprise
sous protection des tribunaux pour
arriver un nouvel accord avec les
créanciers plusieurs formes juridiques
qui pourraient prévaloir honnêtement on
n'a pas décidé formellement il faut
d'abord s'entendre sur quelle serait la
structure de capital comment on peut
libérer l'entreprise de fluo et avec son
air est prise et est je pense province
est l'enjeu principal qu'on va adresser
dans les prochains jours comme ça on va
440 millions de dollars c'est quand même
pas rien on a mis beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup d'argent je comprends le
potentiel mais le marché est baissier
présentement
jusqu'où l'état doit aller pour soutenir
une telle activité est sauvé même une
entreprise fois un compte que si je
pense qu'au prix du diamant actuelle si
on libère l'entreprise de charges
financières il cadre d'opérations sont
relativement faibles d'ailleurs si vous
regardez les résultats financiers sont
louis qui ont été publiés quelques
semaines vous enlevez le bruit
financiers il ya une amélioration
important des opérations alors pour
mener une opération au prix actuel
l'investissement qui requis ou le qatar
qui est relativement minime par rapport
aux milliards que tu investis pour
oublier que 1000 yards investi dans
l'entreprise de marché qui dépend
beaucoup de l'un d'eux notamment pris de
la demande indienne 350 millions de
perte au dernier trimestre c'est quand
même pas rien dans un marché
l'entreprise dit qu'on n'était pas assez
en 2014 de à peu près 150 dollars le
quart à autour de 75 aujourd'hui
alors est-ce qu'on est ce qu'on pense
que ça va remonter parce que c'est un
titre c'est un peu ça alors on se dit le
diamant un potentiel le prix va remonter
notamment question je pense qu'il faut
contextuelle et la période la perte de
350 millions avait une perte ou livre
les radiations d'actifs
je répond différemment si le prix du
diamant pas aux 75 70 à 85 90
l'opération pourrait être cash flow
neutre donc on n'est pas loin du point
d'équilibré et consensuellement faut
comprendre que beaucoup de jeunes afin
qu'ils sont des mercenaires financiers
qui ont considéré que de perdre 2
milliards étaient moins intéressant que
de donner un peu d'eux
des perspectives à moyen terme alors je
pense que cette décision qui va venir
voir ces mots choc entre valence et le
programme je pense que tu annoncé que
les sommes qui sont requises pour
permettre de continuer sont pas si
alexis donc à 90 dollars c'est rentable
et ça vous dit on arrive on conclurait
fois l'argent de le milliard de
milliards investis requiert beaucoup
plus enfermé au moins on me dit il faut
pas oublier que 550 emplois la
communauté qui rit et à vérifier aussi à
beaucoup d'emplois sont là dedans les
redevances financière le clame y ait
beaucoup de retombées économiques
importantes ce projet on aura perdu
combien sur les 440 millions pour le
mieux jusqu'à maintenant je peux plus
attendre aux jeunes dansent convenant
aussi le plein
c'est sûr que sur le milliard
l'entreprise auprès milliards
aujourd'hui
sauf que le pont soit le lithium vous
avez fait des annonces matin puis on
aura la pdg de propulsion québec un peu
plus tard dans l'émission pour parler
vraiment du potentiel du lithium mais là
aussi on veut des investissements parce
qu'on voit le potentiel avec la voiture
électrique le développement du lithium
ion québec a déjà investi quand même pas
mal d'argent dans nemaska lithium qui
est aussi une entreprise qui a connu sa
part de difficultés jusqu'où on va donc
tes grands chevaux du lithium on essaie
de ses rangs du diamant je passe quand
on regarde les pronostics pour les
voitures électriques
on parle de multiplicateur de crise à 25
fois ce qu'on a aujourd'hui on regarde
les gisements minéraux de lithium dans
le monde et on peut conclure assez
rapidement que les trois projets ont
pardonné masse quand on parle de notre
médium pour passer de sales yu-na qui va
peut-être passer la corde bape ces
gisements d'or sont requis pour la
production ultime de batteries a je
pense qu'on a un environnement assez
porteur pour que le gouvernement veuille
vous le rêvez c'est dans cette orgie
lithium qui pourrait évoluer ou frigide
fin de battery group captain médias vous
avez dit fière parce qu'on a donné 5 15
millions à group captain médias jusqu'à
maintenant 5 millions sur votre
gouvernement des 10 5 millions ce pas la
fin du monde quand même de l'argent
public
encore là jusqu'où on va pour aider les
médias mais pour aider des entreprises
dont le modèle d'affaires ne fonctionne
plus j'aimais vraiment contextualiser 5
millions vous convaincre que 5 millions
kimi chez les canadiens et pour
permettre de couvrir les pertes
d'opérations qui vont être encourues
jusqu'à la fin doit décembre
l'alternative était de fermer simplement
que tu aimes les dix ans qui était en
effet dit que nous ne voulions pas au
gouvernement le droit d'information est
essentiel et s'ils ont pu avoir une
diversification c'est encore mieux
donc les 5 millions relative et de
l'utiliser par rapport à l'autre
alternative était préférable inclut un
des repreneurs qui ont fait surface
alors nous pensons que avec le programme
comme annoncée bientôt avec maman
nathalie roy la collègue de
communication et culture me suggéra au
niveau des finances je pense que le
problème qu'on va annoncer ou début
octobre pourrait permettre à des
repreneurs de reprendre capter médias en
totalité ou en partie et je pense que
c'est important crédit d'impôt sur les
salaires par exemple il ya plusieurs
outils dans notre corporation
c'est une option parmi d'autres mais
vous avez raison le gouvernement ne peut
pas ne doit pas être le seul pourvoyeur
d'aidé des pertes potentielles le modèle
doit être changés l'euro d'une violence
et d'une charge de la batterie est ce
que vous allez demander des garanties
d'emploi parce qu'on a entendu la
possibilité qu'une entreprise comme
quebecor par exemple reprennent le
groupe 4n media
mais ce serait au prix de beaucoup de
pertes d'emplois est ce que vous allez
soutenir les médias mais en retour de
garanties qu'ils n'en voient le modèle
des médias qui est brisé conséquemment
le nouveau modèle qui va faire une
pérennité avec des programmes propres et
met en place vont requérir un ajustement
du maghreb de la semaine ce modèle
pourrait passer par une certaine
réduction d'effectifs
on est mieux avoir des capitaux des
médias égyptiens qui vont avoir une
pérennité avec -1 polycom avoir du tout
se peut-il que sur les six journaux de
ketele médias en est certains qu'ils ne
survivent pas c'est pas son nom au nord
on a engagé la firme séquestre personnaz
pour garder la vente en totalité le vent
pas partie est ce qu'on voit
présentement du tout beaucoup trop tôt
il ya beaucoup d'intérêts des
communautés parce qu'on joue un coup de
monde sensibilisation la communauté sur
la réalité des médias écrits et d' assez
évident car on pourrait voir des
communautés d'intérêts
régionales je prends ma main